[Music]
I've always wondered about ghosts they
clearly can pass through walls but then
why don't they just drop through the
floor and fall into the basement
basement should be full of ghosts but
they're not what's up with that how many
are there well there's about 80 billion
people who have ever lived there we've
got eight billion people alive today
that's 10 ghosts of dead people for
every living person walking this Earth
that's too crowded why aren't there more
of them why they gotta go to special
places at certain times and only see
some of them they should be everywhere
and they're not and where will
why is it that every time somebody
becomes a werewolf it's only because
they're outside and they happen to be
looking up and then notice the full Moon
the Moon has been full the whole night
all they had to do is check the phase
tables for the moon they could have
become a werewolf much earlier in the
evening and they didn't they could have
become a werewolf while they were eating
dinner check your astronomical tables
werewolves